mais les du tube on joueront sur un
vieux au bistrot du théâtre je vous en
prie à montigny-le-bretonneux
pour participer à cette émission café
politique vous êtes la toute nouvelle
maire de la verrière élu par le conseil
municipal le 14 avril dernier après le
départ d'alain jason va y revenir tout à
l'heure on va parler de votre parcours
de vos engagements votre regard aussi
peut-être un peu quand même sur les
sujets d'actualité
vous êtes donc mr maire communiste il y
en a de moins en moins en france malgré
tout les maires communistes si on prend
l'exemple de livres de france en plus
ici on prend l'exemple de l'île de
france au dernier scrutin de 2014 il ya
eu des pertes de bastions comme bobigny
en seine-saint-denis villejuif dans le
val-de-marne
j'aimerais savoir justement pour vous ce
que ça signifie être communiste
aujourd'hui défendre des valeurs
d'abord justice sociale égalité hommes
femmes particulièrement donc c'est avant
tout des valeurs et quand on a une
mairie en général en effet de mettre en
pratique les valeurs qu'on défend votre
parti communiste aujourd'hui c'est le
seul vrai parti de gauche c'est la
gauche
il est à gauche manifestement par contre
c'est pas la seule force de gauche jean
en exclu le gouvernement socialiste
quand même permettre des mois mais non
c'est pas la seule force de gauche y en
a d'autres ne serait ce que dans le
front de gauche on a essayé de mettre en
place
et puis d'autres partis politiques
qu'ils sont
de gauche c'est qu'ils sont aussi
légitimes que nous apporter leurs
valeurs là et on va rentrer dans une
année de campagne électorale puisque
2017 sur la présidence qui incarne le
mieux la gauche aujourd'hui selon vous
quel homme de gauche un fan de gauche en
2010 est par exemple
non non ce temps cette question du
parrainage aussi parce que je devais lui
est maire il faudra aussi montent
actuellement accordés parrainage sera
candidat le quand le moment sera venu on
en aura un qui portera les valeurs de la
gauche qu'on aura défini ensemble pour
l'instant c'est plus sur le programme
qu'il faut qu'il faut s'arrêter écrit
jean luc mélenchon pierre laurent le
programme d'abord et on verra après
justement parce que vous allez être
sollicité un jeu les dire en tant que
maire sur cette cette question là pour
obtenir le parrainage sans me donner non
parce que je bouge bien qu'on
réfléchisse et notamment par rapport au
programme mais vous allez vous impliquer
sur votre commune vous allez essayer de
faire vivre cette campagne aura une
campagne législative aussi qui va
forcément être la présidentielle pour
faire et on fait vos idées de gauche
aujourd'hui ces idées de gauche vous les
sentez vous malmenez justement réalisant
quelques difficultés à se faire entendre
enfin c'est plus compliqué ça je crois
le valeurs de gauche qui sont je crois
toujours très présentes dans le pays
et puis pour l'instant
des gens de gauche qui se demandent
comment
comment les faire vivre et comment les
faire
montée en puissance mais les valeurs
les valeurs elles sont toujours là je
crois vous parlez avec les gens les
valeurs de solidarité de justice
d'égalité
c'est même à mon avis en puissance après
comment
comment rassembler comment donner
cohérence à tout ça et faire un projet
commun qui permette de gagner est en
tout cas même si vous donnez pas de nom
du du candidat que vous pourriez
éventuellement soutenir ce qui est
certain c'est que si françois hollande
était candidat au second tour par
exemple vous n'iriez pas voté pour lui
très franchement
pour l'instant ce qu'on voit françois
hollande en cette fin de mandat faire
quelques cadeaux en tous cas quelques
signes vers un électorat plus plus à
gauche je pense aux enseignants par
exemple dans les salaires sont sont à la
prime en tout cas été un petit peu
augmenté pour la prochaine rentrée il ya
on parle d'une éventuelle baisse des
impôts aussi font des gestes déjà un peu
tardif quand même et puis ça donne pas
la cohérence
et l'objectif à long terme
sauf que ça c'est un gouvernement qui a
quand même remis à peu près tout ce
qu'il avait dit
tout ce qu'il avait promis on a la
mémoire un peu plus longue que l'année
qui arrive quoi embellir et donner
beaucoup d'autres autre signe vous dites
il ya toujours cette volonté de gauche
tout cas ses idées de gauche qui reste
dans la dans la société cette volonté de
justice sociale de dialogue aussi par
exemple il ya le mouvement nuit debout
c'est ce qu'illustre le mieux je pense à
ça parce que sur votre commune de bouée
justement a également juré vu le jour et
puis j'ai été dire bonjour
non mais oui enfin ça fait partie des
mouvements mais au même titre que le
parti communiste le trim que le npa en
titre que
ensemble etc ça fait partie des moments
qui se cherche et je t'aime mon espoir à
moi c'est qu'à un moment donné tous ces
mouvements qui se cherche trouve un
terrain d'entente qui trouve un
un programme
minimum mais parce que derrière il faut
se structurer à avoir des idées à
exposer à g et un moment un moment il
faut passer par là donc
voilà je propose de passer en salle à
présent va poursuivre ce café politique
avec vous je vous en prie
oh
l'invité du café politique aujourd'hui
n'est duthu maire pcf de la ville de la
verrière toute récente mer donc puisque
élu le 14 avril après le départ d'alain
jaj pour raisons de santé il était en
poste depuis 2012 tout cas en tant qu'
en tant que maire même s'il était là
avant le conseil municipal
il reste d'ailleurs au sein de la
majorité comment vous avez appris
accueilli son départ quelle était votre
réaction
forcément un petit peu compliqué quand
même d'abord en déjà eu la maladie tout
n'a pas été simple
ça n'est pas motivée par des raisons de
santé et besoin de se reposer un petit
plus est
et quand tu nous a dit qu'il partait ça
a été quand même un show qu'on va dire
on peut le dire comme ça parce que on
était d'abord très
cette majorité très soudée autour de son
maire
le programme qu'on a sur lequel on s'est
fait élire on l'a partagée mais il l'a
il a porté vraiment dans l'air très très
très impliqué ce qui fait que quand il
nous a dit qu'il devait partir
et lui-même étaient bien bien triste
nous on a eu un moment fois digérée
normaction et pour essayer de rebondir
et une fois ensuite la nouvelle tombée à
quel moment c'est la candidature le
choix de la candidate s'est fait pour la
majorité
à quel moment elle a un jeu vous a dit
ou pas d'ailleurs ce sera vous
assez vite en fait puisque entre le
moment où ils annoncent qu'ils
démissionnaient le moment où des scènes
vraiment espace en moi donc on n'a pas
vraiment trop le temps de
de réfléchir et
ou même temps c'est la candidature est
assez logique puisque
un jeune maire front de gauche partant
amer que c'est pour une gauche qui
reprend tu es quelqu'un c'est dans la
politique puisque l'année scolaire
réaliste il ya la styliste un petit peu
la même peu ouverte et avec de vollard
il ya des membres du parti socialiste
qui a beaucoup beaucoup de membres non
ils sont 7 et
et ma candidature ce
a fallu la ligne qui vous l'avez vu au
vote mais
déjà avant le vote n'a pas posé partie
du problème puisque c'était assez dans
la logique des choses comme si vous
aviez imaginé un moment devenir meilleur
dans cette commune de la verrière
non après l'arrachage après percer l'un
court qui lui aussi pendant trente ans
mais emblématique de la commune
non non pas du tout donc un moment aucun
problème ressenti beaucoup de pression
au moment où vous avez reçu cette
écharpe en tout cas où beaucoup de oui
comme beaucoup de responsabilités mais
bon après
quand on est engagé politiquement et
qu'on fait tous les militants depuis
très longtemps on assume jusqu'au bout
et oui c'est pas rien pour écouter un
micro trottoir à présent nous sommes
nous allés voir les habitants de la
verrière pour leur demander si vous
connaissez déjà quand même un petit peu
et puis nous attendait de vous je
connaissais quelques personnes dans
l'équipe municipale mais la personne qui
a remplacé le maire je la connais pas je
sais que d'anciens maires et l'ait fait
un travail donc après je pense qu'avoir
prendre la suite du jour au lendemain
comme ça reprendre les fonctions de
maire c'est pas évident avec lui surtout
qu'il après il ya des projets qui font
que peut-être qu'il ya plein de choses à
s'occuper avant de venir nous voir je
pense je connais pas très bien le vo mer
mais l'ancien le connaissait bien quoi
le bois de l'étang ils veulent le
devenir
on se connaissent tous c'est une famille
on vit ensemble et ils veulent détruire
une journée contre quoi non je ne sais
pas ce que j'attendais elle continue sur
la lancée voilà un peu de sécurité
on a besoin mais déjà le soir l'été ici
vaut mieux parler dans le parc
c'est à nos risques et périls c'est pas
terrible les courses de moto sur la
grande rue c'est pas terrible non plus
puis a besoin de peu de propreté les
gens peut-être un petit déficit de
notoriété
nous avons un sentiment parce que vous
avez déjà commencé à faire le tour de
l'étang de la commune nouveau présenter
et échanger avec les habitants
on connaissait les faits notoires avec
quelques habitants sont sur le
le côté secours peu
bois de l'étang j'allais me tromper de
près de l'étang j'ai fait du secours
populaire pendant cinq ans là bas donc
effectivement des gens qui le
connaissent
et
aux théories part je suis enseignante à
orly parc depuis un bon moment donc
les parents d'élèves ne connaisse
quelques attentes déjà de s'inscrire
dans la continuité
ce qui paraît assez logique puisque les
gens ont élu votre liste qui était
portée par alger puis quelques attentes
sur des dossiers comme la sécurité aussi
par exemple quelles sont vos priorités
sur cette commande la sécurité on essaie
d'y répondre en partie
avec les caméras qu'on aime
au bois de l'étang et
on y parle avec aussi des médiateurs
écoutez
deux recrues
c'est une question difficile on ne veut
pas commenter abbas et grosses écuries
tout sécuritaire c'est pas notre c'est
un autre façon de faire
après on est conscient que ça pose des
problèmes
on va essayer
mais plutôt par la médiation et et par
le
la réponse à des besoins parce que je
pense ça dépend où certaines fois sans
un petit peu découvrir de jeunes qui
savent pas et
où se mettre
moi je les dis dans mon mon discours
le 14 avril une de mes priorités ça va
quand même être parce que vous avez
aussi la délégation de la jeunesse ce
qu'on veut faire arriver dans cette
commune joueurs prendre un petit peu
l'historique de votre parcours vous avez
58 ans professeur au professeur des
écoles pardon ancien membre du secours
populaire des yvelines première élection
c'était en 2008 où vous étiez justement
adjointe à la jeunesse
comment vous êtes arrivé à ce poste-là
sur la liste à l'époque en 2008 et à
vous occuper de ces questions c'est une
suite logique parce que vous étiez aussi
professeur oui je pense que déjà de par
ma profession
je quand même plus poussés par les
délégations éducative donc ça
m'intéressait et quand quand pierre
c'est là qu'on m'a demandé quel
délégation suisse celle que j'ai demandé
parce que c'est aussi celle que je
connais le mieux
aujourd'hui en tant que maire
j'aimerais qu'on se pose la question
enfin que le conseil municipal entend
dans son ensemble se pose la question de
la jeunesse mais dans ce temps sa
transversalité aussi bien dans le
logement dans l'emploi que dans un peu
dans l'ue
la réussite scolaire
y compris chez les petits dons
comprennent dès le début et confus
combat l'oeil comme ça tout ce qu'il est
possible possible de faire en cohérence
et surtout sur l'aspect politique et
puisqu'on parle de la jeunesse
vous étiez plus jeune vous étiez engagé
en politique déjà ses missions c'est à
dire à la jeunesse communiste j'avais 15
ans faites le calcul
il ya eu un creux et puis pendant ce qu'
ils sont plutôt occupé du sport pour des
choses plus peut-être plus concrète du
quotidien
et ensuite je suis revenue à la
politique parce que il faut s'occuper du
quotidien mais il faut aussi essayer de
changer les choses en profondeur dans
votre famille il y avait une vision
politique plutôt à gauche
est ce que c'est ce que les discussions
portaient sur la vie politique est ce
que oui
mes parents étaient ouvriers tous les
deux syndicalistes
communiste a voté pour donc les valeurs
elles ont été transmises comme ça
moi j'en suis fier on parle des idées de
la gauche les idées de la jeunesse les
idées du féminisme aussi peut-être êtes
la première femme donc à la tête de la
ville de la verrière
qu'est ce que ça peut changer pour la
verrière et qu'est ce que ça change dans
la façon de faire de la politique
alors je suis pas féministe en dans le
sens où je vais porter comme ça je le
suis dans le sens où je pense qu'une
femme à toutes les
toutes les capacités
égale un homme et je vois pas la
différence quand on me dit que ton petit
rabais si je me prends j'en prends
conscience quand on me le dit parce que
c'est en tant que femme que fin -
comment c'est pareil donc l'égalité elle
est dès le départ le problème c'est
qu'elle n'est pas dans les faits c'est
c'est pas
moi mon féminisme le portons tous les
jours
dans l'action que je mène quand vous
êtes la commune de la verrière fait
partie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
voisins-le-bretonneux plaisir les clés
ce sont trois communes qui se dirigeait
aussi par des femmes mais d'un autre
bord plus on dit c'est la même chose à
tous hommes femmes mais est-ce que ça
facilite quand même les rapports les
échanges parce que c'est moins virulent
contre 2h l'instant rien n'est prévu
je vous dirai ça fallait changer avec la
nôtre mais les autres merdes attendait
ça fait quinze jours donc les rendez
vous sont pris par contre les rendez
vous sont pris dans le courant du mois
de mai elle même dans les quinze jours
qui se sont passés en a pas eu
d'occasions sachant que très rapidement
il va y avoir une séance
9 mai conseil d'installation
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dans un
contexte un petit peu houleux il ya
quelques quelques tensions les élus qui
représente la minorité en tout cas à
saint quentin en yvelines déploré le
fait de ne pas avoir d' une
vice-présidence par exemple visiblement
le 9 mai de l'élection lors de
l'élection il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
changement je faisais comment vous allez
l'aborder à écouter à peu près de la
même façon on va on va faire la même
constatation on va regretter la même
chose qui quand même un peu dommage
parce que c'est ce que vous pensez que
l'espagne de cette agglomération d'une
france sinon qui fonctionne comme ça
est-ce que vous pensez que les relations
peuvent tout de même s'apaiser un petit
peu pour pouvoir travailler aussi aux
côtés
moi je suis de même de par mon caractère
je crois que nous voulons former mais il
ya quand même des principes à tenir
ce sont les principes que ça va très
bien quatre communes de branche
élus tous ne sont représentés sur
l'agglomération
ça pose un petit problème démocratique
quand même et qui reste au bureau
antoine gouy à la vézère échange aussi
un tour à faire mais moi c'est pas
suffisant
c'est pas suffi
on parle de la politique de saint
quentin la politique de la verrière vous
nous avez parlé de la jeunesse il ya des
dossiers importants qui était portée par
votre prédécesseur le futur quartier
gare bécane ces habitations destinées à
faire baisser aussi la part des
logements sociaux de 72 à 50%
il ya aussi la réhabilitation du
quartier du bois de l'étang qui fait
débat avec la population justement ça ce
sont des dossiers qui vont se poursuivre
et accélérer quel rythme vous allez vous
prenez encore vos marques
vous avez déjà bien précise des choses
il ya encore des marques à prendre mais
on va prendre le temps
le quartier du bolide enfin la question
de la rénovation sont partir du bois de
l'étang a été mal comprise ou mal
expliqué parce qu'il devrait venir tous
les ans présenté le projet qui a été
aussi animée
quelle que soit l'idée
les raisons du débat
moi mon avis là c'est
rona à plat on discute tranquillement
y'a rien au touquet
qu'il soit urgent dans les mines dans
les deux mois qui viennent
donc prenons le temps de se parler de se
comprendre peut-être un peu plus ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce quartier a besoin
d'une rénovation
les l'intérieur des appartements n'ont
jamais été refait complètement
réellement donc il ya vraiment de quoi
travailler entre les habitants le
bailleur et nous pour faire un projet
qui soit
agréable pour les habitants il ya des
gens ça fait 40 ans c'est un peu normal
que 40 ans après 40 ans de loyer on leur
doit un petit peu quelque chose soit la
ligue mais lot de tensions mais qui leur
passent sur au dessus de la tête
quant au pouvoir
s'accorder pour qu'elle soit enterrée un
bon il ya des choses comme ça où je vois
pas pourquoi pas quelques quelles
seraient les tensions qui pourrait y
avoir entre
trop ni pas ce que c'est
on va expliquer ce projet faire de la
pédagogie en tout cas c'est ce que vous
nous dit bien sûr le les habitants
concernant les habitants on va retourner
à la verrière pour les écouter voir
écouter ce qu'ils pensent de la commune
moi j'ai pratiquement on est là eux
faisait jamais eu vraiment de problème
20 par rapport aux gens qui sont en tout
cas bon civilisé on va dire mais non je
suis pas je me sens bien ici on sent
chavin va je crois dans le sens j'en
suis assez satisfaite non je pense que
c'est surtout un travail pour les jeunes
pour l'emploi et après développer m'a
prié des jeunes aussi pour les activités
qui a une main avant il y en avait des
activités avec les centres de loisirs et
un truc qui a plu donc après si peu pour
mettre ça en place donc ça sera pas mal
on y est bien
on y est bien on serait bien s'il n'y
avait pas toutes ces petites bandes ces
petits gangs ça ça nous gêne
j'aime bien la verrière parce que bon
c'est calme j'ai déjà habité à paris et
tout ça donc c'est call j'ai une fille
de 15 ans et j'ai jamais eu de problèmes
par rapport à cette ville donc que ce
que tu aimes bien la verrière changer
selon vous plus de magasins parce que
deux c'est dans les halls industriels
qui a plus de magasins et sinon à part
ça et la sécurité moi c'est les deux
choses que j'ai toujours la verrière
ville tranquille malgré tout avec
quelques quelques soucis a malgré tout
faux-pas pas non plus minimiser les
réalités qui sont vécues par certains
des habitants au stade ville de la
verrière vous souhaiteriez qu'on en dise
quoi à la fin de votre mandat
c'est une ville où il fait bon vivre que
c'est une bonne dynamique que c'est une
ville j'aimerais bien les
les gens sont là dit un souci du % de
logements sociaux
donc les gens sont
dans les difficultés financières en
difficulté tout 6
si elle chez eux quand ils rentrent chez
eux quand ils le sont je trouve une
ville agréable à vivre
forcément il va y avoir beaucoup de
discussions dans les prochains mois avec
l'élection présidentielle on a abordé
brièvement au début de l'émission
l'élection législative
aussi cette commune de la verrière vous
en tant que maire vous abordez commencé
ses échéances on parle d'une gauche qui
mettrait en difficulté on imagine même
le front national au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle par exemple et
me faire c'est du front national dans
toutes les communes
j'imagine que vous allez aussi peut-être
vous engager en tant que maire les dans
cette compagnie faire passer nos idées
montrer que ce n'est pas la solution au
front national par exemple sur
son objet d'art aux dernières élections
il ya eu on a été une des villes par
petit fils certes mais une des villes le
à botul plus à gauche donc on reste un
bastion très à gauche
dans le coin c'est peut-être pour ça que
que nos adversaires net même s'il a tout
de même magazine soit une progression
d'à quoi bien sûr mais on a une gauche a
vraiment très ancrée donc et peut
s'appuyer quand même sur nos habitants
et puis on va
enfin moi je m'engage oui bien sûr je me
suis toujours engagé c'est pas
aujourd'hui que je vais arrêter
pas forcément en tant que maire mais
aussi en tant que citoyen voilà 2020 ce
sera la fin de ce mandat municipal
saucisse est repoussé vous imaginez déjà
briguer un autre mandat
quelle question
non on sait qu'à celles en cours sur la
commune est resté maire pendant 30 ans
mais trente ans vous imaginez là ce que
je vais avoir ma non non non non ça se
pose pas qu'en fin vraiment cgt aucun
moment vous êtes la question quand vous
en avez parler même avec un lynchage
vous dire voilà il faut aussi penser
parce que ça fait partie des choix
politiques faits intéressants les
stratégies mais il ya forcément une riri
qui sont ici on garde la municipalité
pour la perdre dans 80 voire personnes
le pensent
roll
toute la réflexion politique cette fois
sera de voir comment
comment
créée la suite je l'essaie j'ai pas de
j'ai peu de solution à vous proposer
tout de suite merci youtube invités dont
ce café politique ainsi merci
à